you can come see me you know the castle
block I can't you think anyone will dare
tell you we're not allowed I'm not going
back North Murray guy what's west of
Westeros I don't know no one knows it's
where all the map stop that's where I'm
going
hi everyone its Charlie you guys may
have heard George R Martin comment about
doing a game of Thrones sequel series
for Arya Stark after the events of A
Song of Ice and Fire I'll explain what
the story of that actually is in my top
I prequel videos updated based on recent
comments from HBO because they've
changed a couple things with their
development of all the different prequel
series that are going on right now so if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Game of Thrones
A Song of Ice and Fire videos I'll be
doing videos for the prequel as we learn
more about that they're shooting Blood
Moon right now because we're past the
main show now what I'll do is I'll
change the giveaway to the books right
now so all you have to do to enter that
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video the big thing about the
Arya sequels story is that George R
Martin talked a while ago separately
from all the recent interviews that he's
been doing about the show's ending
versus his book ending because as you
would expect all the news outlets are
going to him asking about how his ending
is gonna be the same or different from
the show's ending so a long time ago he
just talked about doing the continuing
Adventures of Arya when she left
Westeros at the end of the story because
there was a recent interview where he
basically said that his ending to a Song
of Ice and Fire and dream of spring will
be very similar to what's happening on
the show with some minor changes I don't
think Dan and Dave's ending is gonna be
that different from my ending because of
the conversations we we did have but
they may be on certain secondary
characters that may be the big
differences there was another interview
from Isaac Hempstead write this sort of
corroborates that and what the producers
did even though obviously we got kind of
the Cliff Notes version of the story so
even if he does very similar things
it'll feel very different just because
you get so much more context for why the
characters do the things that they do in
these big moments at the end of the
story
so really the Arya sequel story is sort
of a hard-boiled detective thriller bent
not necessarily her being a faceless
person but her using her faceless person
abilities to solve crimes and get into
all kinds of trouble during her King
continuing adventures especially after
she goes west when he was making these
comments he also talked about Braavos
and going back east so I think the idea
is is that at the end of the story Arya
Stark is going to the Western continent
but she's not gonna permanently settle
in any one place so adult arya will just
be globe-trotting all over the place so
think of the sequel story is the
continuing Adventures of the cat of the
canals that type of Arya Stark seeking
new challenges following ass-backwards
in to adventures just having all kinds
of fun the really interesting thing that
just happened though the Isaac Hempstead
right interview that everybody's been
talking about the last couple of days is
that he didn't interview with the
official HBO making Game of Thrones blog
so this is just a random blogger out
there asking him questions
this is HBO using one of their people in
one of their platforms to officially
publish information and get him talking
about his ending during this interview
he says that the producers explained
that they were doing George R Martin's
book ending that Martin told them
himself a few years ago during the
now-famous Santa Fe story meetings that
everybody's been quoting the last couple
of weeks this is his actual quote from
the interview so remembered this is an
official HBO person doing this blog post
with him so he says the producers told
me that there were two things George or
Martin had planned for bran and that was
the Hodor revelation about how he got
his name and that bran would be king so
that's pretty special to be directly
involved in something that is part of
George's vision it's a really nice way
to wrap it up what this information
means is is that they're basically
trying to do George RR Martin's ending
albeit the CliffsNotes version of his
ending so it's totally understandable
that everyone's unsatisfied with the way
we got to the ending
even though there'll be a lot of
different side characters that are
present for everything that's going on
and because of the POV nature of the
books you'll actually understand why
certain characters are making these
decisions at the end of the story and
think about it this way how big is one
of George RR Martin's books it's
enormous
imagine the story of the last three
episodes of Game of Thrones after they
wind up killing the night king being
dream of spring so they basically took
what was thousands and thousands of
pages of book material and condensed it
down to a couple hours of television
speaking of books coming out George r
Martin also made some recent comments
about winds of winters release date and
he just said that if he doesn't get it
out by the end of 2020 that he's going
allowed the fans and his people around
him to lock him up in prison until he
actually does finish it so either we're
gonna see winds of winter by the end of
2020 or we're gonna see george RR martin
in a prison cell for the rest of his
life but HBO did a big update on all the
prequels a little while ago George R
Martin has made a lot of comments about
the different prequel stories like I
said there are three in active
development right now - in the script
phase in the one that they're shooting
is the long night Blood Moon prequel I
know they're a couple big picks on
everyone's wish list for Game of Thrones
prequel stories these are my top 5 picks
and martin has also said a couple
prequels they're definitely not doing
that I'll talk about after my list here
so this takes those into account but
starting with number 5 the long night
Blood Moon prequel obviously how is that
going to be different from the main
shows take on White Walkers the night
king in that period in history the way
that HBO pitched the series in their
synopsis is is that history might not be
quite as accurate as you think it is
based on all the world of Ice and Fire
history that we've read because that's
where a lot of the material for this
show is going to come from my take on
that is they're just gonna do the good
version of the White Walkers in the
night king not the CliffsNotes version
that the main show did so you'll
understand way more about what's going
on with these characters as the White
Walkers are created but HBO hasn't said
specifically when the show is going to
start if it's gonna start with a pact
between the children and the first men
after they created the White Walkers or
if it's going to start sometime before
that once we learn a little bit more
about that I'll talk a little bit more
about stories from that period we do
know quite a bit of history from that
era like the unification of the north
there's a lot of other really big events
that were happening around Westeros that
they might cover during the long night
blood moon prequel series number four is
the doom of Valyria you may remember
back during 2018 there was reports going
around the internet from publications
that the working title for one of the
prequel series was Empire of ashes
whether or not they wind up making that
or folding that into the long night
prequel series remains to be seen but I
think that there's gonna try and
separate the doom of Valyria out just
because it's such a huge event that it
be better to cover it on its own series
and the timeline doesn't really line up
because the rise the Valyrian freehold
happened after the end of the first long
night that they refer to on the show
they're going to be covering during the
long night blood moon prequel series
three is the Empire of the dawn in the
blood
Stone Emperor this is basically the
ancient eastern empire of ET the rise
and fall of the empire AVT you have to
imagine that happening before the events
of the long night so we're talking tens
of thousands of years ago this area over
in the far east north of the jade see
per their cultures legends their first
ruler was sort of a Jesus figure the son
of the God that they worshipped the lion
tonight in the maiden made of light he
ruled for ten thousand years till his
son the Pearl Emperor rose to the throne
for a thousand years then he passed to
his son the Jade Emperor the tourmaline
Emperor the Onyx Emperor the Topaz
Emperor in the opal Emperor this will
sound very familiar to Targaryen history
so each successive emperor in the great
dawn Empire ruled for increasingly short
amounts of time it's sort of an amalgam
for what happened to the Targaryens
dragons over time they started to grow
smaller and smaller be more and more
diminished eventually the daughter of
the opal Emperor the amethyst Empress
rose to the throne her envious brother
cast her down and proclaimed himself the
bloodstone Emperor and began a reign of
terror and slavery in which he practiced
dark arts necromancy and took a tiger
woman for his bride feasted on human
flesh and cast down the gods of et to
worship the black stone fallen from the
sky the maesters of the Citadel refer to
this event in their cultures history as
the blood betrayal in the beginning of
their long night all happening before
the original long night the tale of the
great dawn empires long night goes on to
say that a great warrior rose up an
azure high figure Lily the virtuous into
battle with a sword Lightbringer in his
hand light was restored but the great
Empire was not reborn or restored the
world became a broken place where every
tribe of man went its own way
fearful of all the others and war lust
and murder had endured so you can see a
lot of the very obvious similarities in
that ancient mythology that Martin
writes foreshadowing his book ending for
Song of Ice and Fire
just because the characters defeat the
knight Cain doesn't mean that everybody
gets their happy ending number 2 my next
pick is the Blackfyre rebellion the
first Blackfyre rebellion I think is
just one of the most interesting events
in Westerosi history that it'd be
interesting to see in an actual prequel
series King Aegon Targaryen the fourth a
very Robert
Ratheon type of Targaryen king very
lusty had many many bastards on his
deathbed legitimized them all it even
though per traditional rules his oldest
legitimate son Daeron ii was ascending
to the throne at his death but Aegon
favored his eldest bastard at daemon and
gave him the ancestral Targaryen
Valyrian blade black fire which had
previously been seen as the right to
rule whoever became the heir apparent
would wield black fire as they took the
Iron Throne so by giving the sword to
his eldest bastard and legitimizing him
he caused this crazy succession issue
whereby half the realm felt like daemon
the bastard would have been the better
king for Westeros the other half of the
realm supporting the legitimate heir
Darren the second Damon takes the name
black fire after he's legitimized forms
house Blackfyre in most of egg ons
bastards flocked to him with half of the
realm and his big civil war starts one
of the other bastards of Aegon the
fourth was the Bloodraven himself the
three-eyed raven that we saw in the TV
show even though they never really did
that history so this would be one of
those prequel series where you could
actually see a much younger version a
young man version of the three-eyed
raven in my number one pick is obviously
the dance of the Dragons another
Targaryen Civil War but one that
involves way more dragons and just seems
like it could be way more cooler
visually on-screen some of the events of
that Civil War mirrors what happened
between Jon Snow and Daenerys in the
final couple episodes of Game of Thrones
with Daenerys becoming fearful that he
would try to take her claim to the Iron
Throne during the dance of the dragons
what happened is is that King Viserys
the first had a bunch of children but he
didn't have a male heir so he sort of
grooming his oldest daughter
Ranieri the first to become queen after
he died eventually he pulled a King
Henry the eighth and got remarried to
another woman Alison Hightower and had a
son by her then named him heir to the
Iron Throne so what happened is is that
his oldest daughter from his first wife
got into a war with the son from the
second wife you could probably also draw
some parallels between the fake version
of Aegon in the golden company plot
that's happening in the books right now
in real life Jon Snow because
technically Jon Snow would have been a
second son from another wife that
Rhaegar Targaryen had but George are
Martin likes to do that even though the
dance of the Dragons is a very
well develop story he's using it to
foreshadow a lot of the conflicts that
are happening in the main novels of A
Song of Ice and Fire
but because a lot of people ask about
these prequels Martin has already said
that they're definitely not going to do
Robert's rebellion because they're
already covering a lot of those events
on the main series and they're not gonna
do tales of Dunkin egg because Martin
still plans on writing new material for
that at some point and he doesn't want
HBO to do a story that he's not finished
with in the books yet again like they
did with the main series so let me know
which of the prequel series do you want
them to do for Game of Thrones in future
years right now they're probably just
gonna do the long night Blood Moon
prequel series then maybe three four
years down the road we'll start hearing
about them starting a second prequel
series I'm still working on a prequel
predictions video that should post in
the next couple of days congratulations
to the winner from my last big game of
Thrones giveaway Britney Turner please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your details click here for
that Game of Thrones Season 8 bonus
episode in my deleted scenes video and
click here for all my Game of Thrones
finale in Easter Egg videos thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
you